hi all bismil alhamdulillah assalamu
alaikum greetings of peace
it is time for those of you
in the muslim world as if we have some
deep embedded religious conflict and a
hate between jews and muslims and that
is so
deplorable despicable now we have a
special episode some recent events have
developed some news has been brought to
our attention i have been informed by
many sources
about the famous jordan peterson that i
have developed an audience in the muslim
world
that the muslims suddenly these guys
allegedly hate jews now real quickly who
is jordan peterson for as an outsider
you have no idea how much you don't know
about what you don't know even you're
blind to your own ignorance jordan
peterson is a canadian clinical
psychologist youtuber author and a
professional professor emeritus at the
university of toronto he began to
receive widespread attention from the
muslim community when he stood firm
against the attack on the children in
the schools and elsewhere by the
alphabet movement and he had other
stances where he was brave enough to
come out and stand firm on
and he was also brave enough to have a
few muslim personalities on his program
and in these interviews that he had with
these i don't i wouldn't say that i have
a tangible understanding of islam
personalities he pulled back
he adjusted and he admitted
that he knew very very little about
islam as a religious
system a system of thought islam has
remained relatively opaque to me despite
the fact that i've done a reasonable
amount of historical reading and even
though he had all this knowledge
in many other areas
uh his blunder that he made about
prophet muhammad being a warlord he
ended up taking that back in fact
i will actually argue today that the new
testament representation of jesus christ
in his second coming is way more violent
than muhammad's
conquests in the medina okay the term
warlord that you use with the prophet
you've never used with harry truman
you've never used with uh
with uh roosevelt you've never used with
winston churchill all of which conquered
countries literally in wars he was also
someone who we had high hopes for as he
got to
[Music]
[Music]
learn some of the basics
of islam with
people such as muhammad
and the bare bones basics is first to
say that we believe in god one god
uh worthy of worship is that this would
disqualify something like the trinity
from being true and in fact the quran
this is the islamic position uh is
vehement in its uh opposition towards a
triune god and hamza youssef i'm trying
to figure out
how to be a jew and a christian and a
muslim at the same time
but become muslim that's the best way
because the beauty of islam is you get
the old testament the new testament the
last testament i mean that really is
for me
even the jews acknowledge this because
islam in many ways is a universalized
judaism it's judaism for the gentiles
and we were very excited that he was
going to come around accept the pure
monotheism of the worship of the creator
not the creation but sadly enough
with all that excitement he had a
message to the muslims and we were
thinking maybe he's going to come out
and say la illahi there's nothing worthy
of worship this is in the fitrah in the
human being that of the except the crate
of the heavens and the earth
and
he made another blunder so we're going
to discuss that blunder
and he gave the muslims some action
items and we're going to give him some
action items it's only fair with my next
guest dr sabi ahmad salaam alaikum and
dr bill wake up there are over 300
million americans that don't know what
islam is this is why we are opening the
dean center the first of its kind 35 000
square foot tawa center and masjid to
show america the beautiful message of
islam inshallah with your help and
donations we can close on the property
launch nationwide
programs a state-of-the-art production
studio for online content and an on-site
dawah center to show what true islam is
donate right now may god almighty allah
reward all of you
[Music]
peace of peace and blessings of allah be
upon you too brother eddie and to the
listeners
thank you for joining us let's get right
into
without wasting no time get into
the
video the message to the muslims that
jordan peterson just
made
his message essentially boils down to
this
hey muslims stop fighting with vegeta
leave the jews and christians alone your
true enemy is within so make new pen
pals with your imagined and perceived
enemies of islam
and then we'll go ahead and dress it
made a blunder in the past made a
blunder again let's see what we can we
can go ahead and address this it is time
for those of you
in the muslim world
to stop fighting among yourselves you
shiites and sunnis
and also time to stop regarding the
christians and even more specifically
the jews as your enemies
why
so your best bet on the spiritual
warfare front
is to make of yourself and your muslim
practice something so admirable
that the light shining from your
well-constituted psyches and productive
generous and wise actions is so intense
that people convert to your faith from
sheer admiration
there's a goal
muslims
reach across the sectarian divide
shiites
find a sunni pen pal
communicate with someone on the other
side sunnis do the same
and then maybe reach out tentatively
to a christian or even heaven forbid a
jew
is there someone in the muslim world
willing to build an electronic system to
bring people from the sunni and shiite
community together
a place where people of goodwill could
reach electronically across the divide
person to person
and to formulate the kinds of personal
trusting friendships upon which a
lasting peace truly might be founded
a place where jews and christians
willing and eager to open communication
with their muslim brothers
might do
just that
there's a task for someone looking for a
purpose and it's an open invitation to
do just that if you build it
they will come
if you build it
get in touch with me you'll figure out
how to do it
and i'll publicize it
thank you
all my muslim listeners
all right dr sabil so where do you want
to start
all right bismillah rahman rahimah i
don't know where to start you know i
mean this video is uh in a way a bit
shocking for me
you know i have been watching jordan
peterson for many years now
i and i really appreciate many topics
that he have done
and the values that he hold which
aligned many times to the islamic values
and the quranic values
so we appreciate that that he has good
intention hopefully right in his heart
when he made this video
however i believe this video is a really
uh
not well thought of
it's really over simplistic in many many
ways it is wrong
so where do i start i mean i don't even
know where to start so let's start off
with uh
the sunnis and the shias that he
mentioned it's kind of like before you
go on go on from there uh you know it's
kind of like somebody throwing out like
you had mentioned uh
and now you have to go ahead and unpack
all of this we've done so many different
programs on it we just had a me and you
had a discussion with a christian uh
pastor and he came
at it with some of these uh bogus claims
that the muslims suddenly these guys
allegedly hate jews it's like someone
what was that uh beautiful example it's
like someone saying when did you stop
stop beating your mother all right
someone asks you these kind of questions
throws it out there then you have to go
ahead and now unpack this stuff when
it's a lot of these untrue statements
and now you're spending time if the
person would have did some homework
first off in a single six-minute 51
second recording peterson manages to
squeeze in every stupid white man's
trope ever told about islam muslims and
the middle east and like you said well
put some plan some education proper
education really thought to south early
you see peterson wants you to believe
that muslims are backwards and barbaric
while white dudes just like him are
educated enlightened and civilized uh
ignorance is something that's uh
affected him before it suggests he's
never read a single book on the history
of the middle east like ever
and he got caught called out but he was
it seemed like sincere and he pulled
back with the warlord comment remember
what prophet muhammad saw
uh and then he had the interview with
muhammad hijab and he pretty much
uh stepped back pulled back from that so
i just wanted to point that out before
you go on that i think this is very
important that
you know uh when you throw these
accusations you throw certain things out
and you have you have uh untruths in
there and now we have to come back and
be try to be on the defensive so please
go ahead
so one statement that he made is about
uh muslims should stop hating the
christians then he said you know god
forbid if you start hating the jewish
people
you know this is such a wrong statement
because muslims we don't hate the jews
because when he made the statement that
muslims should stop hitting the jews it
appears it gives the perception as if
every single muslim hates every single
jew
is that not the perception brother ready
it's exactly there's it's the same pat
it's different packaging from when the
pastor that we had on and he says does
your book teach you to hate causes
infidels teaches you to hate jews and
christians well my my primary issue with
uh
allah islam whatever you want to call it
is that they have no love
uh they don't love the christians and
jews and indian quran unless they have
changed it
they say
about the christians and jews are
infidels
and i haven't heard
any group of so-called leaders of the
muslim folks
come out and denounce that from birth
that it's okay to deceive
the christians and jews you can deceive
them you could befriend them
in order to destroy them
and it's okay to lie to them in order to
destroy them and so i'm just concerned
about that and
i know what
this is just a different packaging
yeah so muslims only have problems with
anyone who is oppressing other humans by
the way
we have problems i mean every human
should have problem every human should
fight the oppressor
it's the great lie told by all colonial
powers and uh in in in favor of the
oppressed
so when we say that you know we have
some friction some problems with some
jewish people it is only those jewish
individuals who are oppressing the
palestinians and the christians up there
by the way the muslims and the
palestinians only them
only those jewish people who have stolen
the land and occupying the land and uh
taking away the dignity and the lives of
the of the innocent people up there yes
we have problem with that right i mean
the whole world should have problem with
that
so there is not a single passage brother
eddie that
gives a blanket statement that muslims
should hate jewish people or any race or
any culture or people of any faith there
is no such statement by the way
you know when i read the bible the old
testament and the new testament
actually there are more things in the
old testament in the in in the new
testament that speaks against the jewish
people how they broke the law how they
are deceiving god and how they are
trying to cut the corners and fire and
trying to have loopholes
even jesus peace be upon him in the new
testament he said many things right and
left quran does not even say those
things by the way against the jewish
people
but important brother eddie for us to
look at from a historical point of view
and i i was hoping that uh
jordan peterson
would have done the homework and look
into history
and find out that what is the cause what
is the problem
of the muslims and the jewish people in
that region he has not done the homework
and he's just making a blanket a general
statement
so when we look into the history what we
will find out is first and foremost
the quran respects jews and the
christians and call them as people of
the book because prophets many prophets
were sent to them many books were sent
to them as a guidance from god and for
all of humanity
so 31 times quran respects and calls the
jewish people and the christians as
people of the book
number two if muslims were hating the
jews you know that's the perception it
creates
why would prophet muhammad peace be upon
him when he moved from makkah to madinah
in the year about 622
one of the very first things that he did
he he formed a constitution called as as
the charter of medina
in the charter of madina it says that
the muslims and the jewish people we
would be one people we will look out for
each other
we will protect each other you know we
will not side with the enemy right so
muhammad sallallahu alaihi sallam peace
be upon him
he gave identity he gave the rights he
gave autonomy right and he gave the
freedoms to the jewish people when the
rest of the world at that time
they were compromising the jewish people
and they were at the brink of extinction
you know there is a professor brother
eddie his name is a doctor dr david
warrenstein he's a jewish professor he's
a jewish scholar in 2012 in the jewish
chronicle he wrote an article and the
title of the article was this
so what did the muslims did for the jews
and the very first sentence he mentioned
in there is that islam saved the jury
islam saved the jury this is an academic
this is a professor this is a jewish man
who is making the statement islam saved
the jury so islam say the jury
the jewish people how
did they get to that if their book
or if they had this
hate
that he's
talking about and this further creates
divide and division because people take
this it's a different packaging just
like again you had that other pastor
packaging in one way it's more
aggressively but this way more it's like
more intellectually and you think and
now this also creates this like oh they
hate us now
you know and now that opens up the door
he thinks he's doing some good but what
are you doing you're opening up the door
for why isn't he not addressing if he if
if he's really sincere because the next
thing he talks about is this pen pal
thing i mean
you have i i have uh
i've had uh rabbis on the program since
we have you rabbi shapiro are you
related at all to ben shapiro
uh i am not and if i was i would not
admit it
zionism which is the ideology that says
jews are a nation yeah as idol worship
if you ask them that the jews and
muslims lived in peace
for for
over a thousand years
and why is it suddenly now suddenly now
that the muslims suddenly these guys
allegedly hate jews
clearly and and suddenly want to kill
them clearly it's zionism that's the
problem it's not islam and it's not musl
it's not muslims against jews that's the
main thing we have to tell people
it's a political thing it's israel it's
not the jews they like to conflate it
because this way number one they get the
support of the evangelicals number two
they have a it's very easy to say if
you're a palestinian you're an
anti-semite we were accepted in these
muslim and arabs we believe in one god
and we were accepted we have different
ways of serving god
but yet
as i they we were respected and even the
muslim religion requires of that
of the uh the muslim people to
to provide protection and hospitality
and they did
carry that out that's clear nobody could
refute this fact
although unfortunately zionism and the
zionist
zionists try constantly to vilify the
muslim people and try to recreate
a a scenario of as if we have some deep
embedded religious conflict and a hate
between jews and muslims and that is so
deplorable despicable and really it's
there's no words it's an aqua and let me
try to explain really people have to
understand you know i threw in words
zionism and this what we're talking
about here yeah what is it most people
are ignorant now when you hear zionism
you know what's the difference between
judaism and zionism a good friend of
mine mikko pillitt for instance who
breaks bread and goes and to the other
side there on the gaza strip
why doesn't he have someone like mikko
pillet on his show he's someone's i dare
him i really let me see how courageous
he is because he obviously
he is a employee for the daily wire
which is by ben shapiro and he's someone
who's designed this i why doesn't he
have his buddy or him why don't they
actually become pen pals with some of
the palestinian the muslim palestinians
out there
in palestine and i think the
palestinians the muslims out there will
be more than welcome to bring them over
just like they brought over mikko pillai
and others so many muslim and christians
also who live in together in peace with
muslims who are being oppressed by a
certain group of people the zionists why
don't they go and visit the people and
they'd be more than willing to be pen
pals right why see the hypocrisy uh but
would would other people be willing to
do that have them over for dinner what
do you think about that it says yeah
that's a good action item you know he's
actually you know yeah he keeps on
saying okay that's a task for you
muslims right somebody should take it
and and he's going to promote it so
that's a task item from doctor for dr
jordan peterson
that have these people on your show and
look into the other side the people who
are oppressed call him on his show and
then that will be a just way a fair way
for him to assess the situation
about the muslims and the jewish people
but again if you look into the history
if muslims wear haters of the jewish
people if that was the perception or
that is what he's going to think then
you know in that article which i
mentioned dr dr david warrenstein he
mentioned
that islam saved the jury multiple ways
in history one of the ways is when the
christians were attacking the jewish
people the christian superpowers of
their time
it was prophet muhammad peace be upon
him who gave the protection and the
autonomy and the freedom to the jewish
people
the second reason that dr david warren
stain a jewish professor he mentioned
is that uh in the spanish inquisition
when the catholics of spain
and of portugal they were forcefully
converting the muslims and the jewish
people throwing them off on the boats
and into the rivers and the oceans and
they were literally killing the jewish
people
at that time brother eddie the jewish
people they did not run to the
christians or to the atheist or to any
other country
they ran to the muslims for their
seclude for their uh safety and muslims
we open our arms we open our homes and
we open our land and we give the freedom
and the protection again to the jewish
people
and then david dr david warrenstein he
said again
that the muslims were the ones in
literally thousands
the jewish people were protected in
world war ii when every every christian
country every european country they were
handing over their jewish people to the
nazi party and to the hitler it where
the muslim countries of turkey and uh
kosovo and bosnia and albania even iran
by the way
they wrote false documents to the jewish
cousins and into the jewish people
saying that they are our citizens not a
single muslim handed over a single
jewish person to the nazis
you know 75 000 jewish people they were
saved by the turkish government
two thousand people they were saved by
the iranians and thousands more by the
other muslim countries so dr jordan
peterson if muslims and islam you know
hates uh
the the jewish people how come they are
protecting the jewish people all
throughout history even now by the way
some of the oldest synagogues in the
whole world they are in the muslim land
you know it just uh it's a lot of just
hypocrisy and then the condescending
tell again we still
have hopes that inshallah god willing he
can get this and you can see the
response by many muslims now that
are talking about this
and it's kind of the narrative that
as if all the problems are in the muslim
world he also wants you to pretend that
violence in muslim majority countries is
the product of ancient rivalries and not
the legacy of colonial divide and rural
strategies where
other people are causing those problems
those issues while
people are getting shot up regularly
here in chicago you know you have uh
just recently you had the highland
shooting
you know this is uh somebody if you look
at who this person in his home he comes
from a christian family nobody's
bringing up his
religion nobody's mentioning anything
about what church his father went
through or what not many people have
disconnected from religion totally right
because of the man-made concepts and you
know the man-made ideas in there and
from from here you see so so much like
gun violence you see so many you know
this is what muslims would love to be a
part of with george peterson things like
this that we could work together but
somehow it's like distraction over there
where people you know you've heard this
rand report where you have deliberate
attempts to cause chaos and confusion
and destruction in muslim majority
countries to rob them of their natural
resources and why not why doesn't he
address these things you follow me
when's the last time you had like uh
altercation of course intellectually we
don't uh we don't agree with many uh
things right uh many practices
intellectually muslims will go ahead and
based on on
evidence and proof have discussions or
whatnot but to exaggerate it to the
point where and then you have in certain
countries where people
are deliberately
causing these these uh
things that are going on he doesn't uh
he seems naive to this
you know as you mentioned uh correctly
many of the audience right we are not uh
well versed with uh the history of the
muslims uh the quran prophet muhammad
peace be upon him friction between uh
you know some fractions in palestine and
different places if people don't have
knowledge and if they don't know the
history and the context
when jordan p peterson when he comes and
says
these statements it plays into the
misunderstandings and the and the
misconceptions
actually it backfires it creates more
hate and bias and anger
between the communities so that's the
perception he is giving by his over
simplistic and many times wrong approach
to these important historical topics
that's the question now i mean he talks
about
what's in the heart
so you just if he's got to really be
sincere with himself because again you
there
if you're working for some organization
and people who obviously have
have really
put out some derogatory false
information hateful information fed into
the lies and deception about islam and
muslim he's working side by side with
these individuals like ben shapiro and
this organization
and we're more than willing to work
together we don't we're calling out come
let's let's let's go ahead and work
together on a common good right that
there's what's the uh verse in the quran
where god almighty is talking about
let's come to common terms between us
and you that we worship none but the one
creator of the heavens and earth let's
come to a common term between us and you
so we're more than willing you won't now
find the people
who are more i i had
just i had a person and he knows the
history what happened in bosnia not to
get deeper into this i just had a
a clinical
forensic expert and one beautiful thing
that was brought up there is one of the
people from bosnia and this is the
greatest genocide after world war ii a
lady and many bosnians feel this way
that
that there was a
deliberate attempt by the church in this
area and we don't blame all christianity
and all christians obviously but will he
condemn and try to bring peace let's say
we'll give him another task item with
with the p with the with the people in
this community where they have muslims
there who uh had these uh these
atrocities handed uh done to them and
the forensic expert says he was really
just surprised to see like when he was
asked would you forgive the people who
did this he goes how do how can we
forgive would they even have and ask for
our forgiveness
right so
muslims are at that point to forgive but
their muslims are some of the most
oppressed people in the world but you
see how the media and the manipulation
you know is happening so the table is
being turned turned oppressors you know
pressing and then using the media to
make it seem like they are the victims
and now you have him feeding into this
see the the issue of sunnis and shias is
a dead issue by the way if he's trying
to bring it up you know looks like his
mind is stuck like in the late 70s good
point so that is look and now he's
reviving this yeah it's a dead issue and
even the war between the iran and the
iraq it's a proxy war between the two
superpowers i mean i wish you he would
have mentioned that
so it was a it was a war about power
right between the superpowers about
greed and oil and land and occupation
it's not a theological war
unlike the war that we see the hundred
year war used to be between the
catholics and the protestants in europe
so there is more friction going on
between what what do i say the european
countries
and within the u.s itself
so more lives and more oppression is
going on right here in the usa
between the whites and the blacks
between the whites and the whites by the
way right between the democrats and and
uh
the republicans so there is more
friction more oppression more lives and
more racism going on right here and is
now picking up a dead issue
about sunnis and shias without looking
into the historical context and try to
revive it and that obviously is going to
play in the misunderstandings and the
misconceptions people have about islam
so jordan peterson may have good
intention to bring peace but i would say
that peace is not about signing the
abraham accord right people signing it
and automatically peace would be there
see peace is the outcome of justice
if you give justice to the people then
the outcome would be peace
justice in palestine by the way where
their land is taken away their dignity
is taken away it's like a biggest
open-air prison up there
you have to have justice about what's
going on to the muslims in china where
is jordan peterson's voice against that
the big concentration camps two million
muslims
the biggest camps after the world war
two where is his voice so justice has to
be given up there justice has to be done
to the muslims in india by the way
right and left you know lynching and all
the killings going on and oppression
going on about to be genocide where is
jordan peterson right sunishia is a dead
issue by the way
what about uh you know so many what
about russia and ukraine right there i
mean this is a oppression both are
supposed to be christian countries or
christian majority countries forget
about sunnis and shias
they are not even fighting right now but
what about these two christian nations
right there
yeah in russia by the way
thousands of people are killed more war
is coming up unfortunately uh and the
war is you know getting spilled over
nato countries who are predominantly
christian fighting a christian
predominant russia right
so if he is going to be over simplistic
in saying okay sunnis and shias
we can say the same thing let the
christian countries come to peace sit
down right it's an over simplistic way
for us saying it
so the best way dr jordan peterson what
he can do is he can present the topics
number one in the proper context
number two if he feels that every life
is precious then is going to address the
topics of some jewish people oppressing
the muslims in palestine and things are
going on in china he should be bringing
up the topics with a qualified guest
looking into the context speaking out
against the way that he spoke out
against these topics
india by the way right he should get
qualified muslims speaking about the
atrocities which are happening up there
so if he feels that every life is
precious every soul is sacred in the
eyes of god then he should
he should be speaking out against the
oppression of every single human all
over the world and not just pick up the
dead topic of sunnis and the shias
all right so let's uh give him some
action items uh and we're almost out of
time
he you know we were i was really looking
forward to because he was really when
his uh fitrah you know this uh when he
got to hear the quran
he got to hear some of the teachings of
islam you know he almost cried
and you had him eager he said he was i'm
willing and not just willing he was
eager to visit a house of worship
the masjid a mosque i wonder what
happened with that i wonder
when his employers got wind of this i
wonder did he have to now make some
adjustments i is this a deliberate
attempt you know to appease some of his
masters here who are writing those
paychecks i don't know you tell me what
do you guys think and the action items
one of them suggested the pen pal thing
great let's go ahead and get him and his
buddy where they can have conversations
you know about jesus we you see we love
jesus we love to talk about him but i
wonder if action item i like to see him
come on have a nice conversation and
let's see if his buddies there can
really go ahead and come live on what
they believe about jesus what's their
belief like what do they actually
believe about jesus i don't want to
mention it here because you know it's uh
it's something that's i don't think uh
you know we we don't even want to uh
touch upon that it's very uh distasteful
it's very hurtful it's it's blasphemous
so uh that's an action item right there
if you can get his buddies to be to
create some um pen pals and with the
muslims in palestine even the christians
there that's one action item what's
another one uh talks about
i also was thinking of some action item
for dr jordan peterson i hope and pray
that he's listening uh first and
foremost read up on the history of the
muslims right number one
because i mean if you if you don't have
enough knowledge then you should not be
making videos touching upon these topics
secondly read up uh read the quran by
the way and we can help you with that in
the proper context you know many times
he wants to bring solutions to the
different problems around the world i
would say and brother eddie you can
obviously you know concur with me that
islam and the quran in the life of
prophet muhammad peace be upon him it
has solutions complete comprehensive
beneficial practical solutions and we
can make you understand dr jordan
peterson
solutions against
breakdown of the family structure that
you're so high up with right racism gun
violence extremism uh suicides homicides
drug problem gambling problem any
problem that is there in the world quran
has solutions islam has solutions we can
make you understand
you so you can bring myself and brother
eddie on your show and we can sit down
topic by topic number three would be
read up on the issue of palestinians and
the occupation
from both the angles by the way read up
on the issues of the sunnis and shias if
you're going to make a video
regarding that
brush up your knowledge on islam in
general the fundamentals and the
practices
and last but not the least you know
don't just stop at making videos with
good intention about islam and muslims
you should make the videos about
how the christians should stop fighting
how the jewish people should stop their
fighting how the
chinese and the russians and you know
palestinians
all of these people are fictions are
going on so if you want to be complete
and comprehensive with sincerity if you
want peace
all of these action items and me and
brother eddie would be more than happy
just
send us an email we'll be more than
happy to appear on your show and discuss
these topics
so dr jordan peterson one action item of
the all the action items pick up a copy
of the quran and look into the life of
prophet muhammad peace be upon him you
will find out that islam stands for
justice peace unity morality solutions
and success for all of humanity
and i would
if he wants to bring on a guest on his
show to cover
a topic in this region of the world i
highly would recommend he brings on
someone like mikko pillitt i don't think
it's going to happen but this is a
jewish man this is an israeli bring them
on your show bring them on your show
come on our show come and let's see if
we can get you on the show jordan
peterson and be more than willing to
come on your show and and the last
action night this is what i would think
uh i i think this will solve the
majority of your issues and it goes into
the heart
and if you open your heart and your mind
and within yourself you ask the creator
of the heavens and earth alone you say
the one who created me guide me guide me
guide me if you sincerely you don't have
any intermediaries between you and your
creator and you sincerely ask the
creator for guidance have you ever done
that have you ever done that asked the
creator of the heavens center alone for
guidance and then
let's see what happens from there this
is this is an action item i think that
is one of the most important that a
person really is sincere not about the
views not about the popularity not about
to win fame and power and all these
things but at the end of the day you
will be just like all of us in the grave
and
daily wire won't be there your buddy
won't be there it'll be you in that
grave and you will be questioned about
what you believed what you did with your
audience with your time on this earth
and you will be questioned and now this
is what you got to prepare for islam
gives you all the answers to that and
get to know it from its sources
be sincere with it and ask the one who
created you for the guidance
very simple plain and uh we're out of
time thank you dr sabil for being with
us
thank you guys again subscribe if you
haven't already and make sure you guys
also we have the dean center project
that's happening inshallah we'll also
have july 31st uh dr sabil will be there
we have the biggest online
event
happening july 31st
we got surprise guests we got a full
schedule of world-renowned speakers dr
sabile is one of them and starting at
2pm you can watch that at the
deanshow.com live
also on our facebook and
our youtube page again the biggest
online event of the year coming up july
saturday july 31st make sure you are
there wake up there are over 300 million
americans that don't know what islam is
this is why we are opening the dean
center the first of its kind 35 000
square foot tawa center and masjid to
show america the beautiful message of
islam inshallah with your help and
donations we can close on the property
launch nationwide programs a
state-of-the-art production studio for
online content and an on-site dawah
center to show what true islam is donate
right now may god almighty allah reward
all of you
[Music]